Ubisoft is forging a new era of Rainbow
Six Esports and if you ask me
very exciting nine regions an open-ish
circuit and a brand new partnership with
blast Premiere look it's no secret that
competitive Siege and indeed Siege in
general has been down fairly horrendous
since the onset of covid the question is
whether this is enough to breathe a
second life into it
[Music]
all right bros before I start spitting
Siege I must ever so quickly plug our
merch the holiday season is almost upon
us and what better way to treat that
someone special in your life than by
sartorially reminding them to go outside
once in a while our touch grass hoodie
now comes in black and cream colorways
so be a darling and check them out okay
so earlier this week Ubisoft announced
their brand new Forge the new era
era of Rainbow Six Esports there was a
lot of hype surrounding this
announcement and truth be told it didn't
what everyone thought it was going to be
still it was big
really big competitive Siege as we know
it is changing for the foreseeable
future so let's break it down starting
March 2023 the Rainbow Six Esports
Global circuit will boast nine regions
yes nine Europe North America Brazil
Hispanic Latin America Japan South Korea
Asia Oceania and Mina I know these
regions seem very weirdly divided but I
assure you that there is a logic to it
for years certain regions have been
dominated by certain countries resulting
in up-and-coming Esports scenes being
stifled by larger more established ones
by separating say Brazil from the rest
of latim you enable the rest of the
region to grow and compete without being
gate kept from standing on a world stage
each and every time a qualifier rolls
around and for a region like Mina who's
been begging for years to just have a
chance at playing in the big leagues
this is world changing the only way for
these regions to grow and develop is to
offer them an actual Avenue into the
majors and Ubisoft have done that
according to the announcement the
details surrounding the leagues in Asia
Oceania and Mina have yet to be ironed
out but those in na EU Brazil and Japan
will each showcase 10 teams whilst those
in South Korea and Hispanic Latin
America will showcase eight Ubisoft have
branded their new system as a hybrid and
the reason for that is that each of
these regions will have an Open
qualifier which together with the closed
League will determine who gets to play
at the major that takes place at the end
of each stage the 2023 season will
consist of two three month long stages
the first is followed by a three month
long off-season and the second by a
two-month-long offseason after that
there's the Invitational which will no
longer have an Open qualifier you need
to qualify by way of points which
honestly I'm not sure how I feel about
it given that SI is quite literally
model old after TI it does sort of feel
like it should have and anyone can enter
and win component like that's just part
of its DNA you know as for the majors
since we now have nine regions and
there's only two majors per year they're
adding an additional phase to each
tournament that precedes the group stage
and playoffs sort of like the Challenger
stage of a CS go major speaking of Cs go
Ubisoft closed their announcement video
by revealing that they'd entered a
multi-year partnership with blast
premiere for those of you who don't
actually watch a ton of Cs go blast have
earned a lot of respect and admiration
from the csgo community over the past
couple of years their production value
is considered First Rate by many and
despite holding smaller events than say
ESL pgl or even starlighter they produce
what many consider to be world-class
offerings for blast to be bringing that
level of production value to Siege is
just
I am actually getting hyped just
thinking about it as for the circuit
itself you might be looking at the
schedule and thinking that's a lot of
downtime between stages
what's gonna fill it well aside from
offering plenty of time for rest and
recuperation which is genuinely
important it will in fact give third
party organizers a chance to hold Siege
tournaments which is huge I could go on
and on about why open circuits are
indeed the very lifeblood of Esports and
why they benefit orgs viewers sponsors
and competitors alike but suffice it to
say this is exactly the injection of
organic Grassroots competition that
Siege was in need of in fact it was
exactly this kind of third-party
involvement that used to play a huge
role in CG Sports and it's fantastic to
see Ubisoft hearkening back to that
earlier business model bring back the
dream hacks the oga piss hell give me a
Beyond The Summit Siege event that would
be sick not only will this new system
open up the esport competitively
creatively and indeed financially but
it'll make it so that with the help of
our six share orgs are more enticed to
get into Siege in the first place think
about it some random LFO stack qualify
for a major without having to be in a
closed League win the major and before
you know it they're getting signed by
100 thieves now to be fair there are
also a lot of unanswered questions
regarding this new circuit it's good to
be excited I know that I am but it's
also important to temper that excitement
with the uncertainty of what's to come
there are a lot of individual leagues
that now have to stand on their own and
a lot of downtime in between the now
reduced number of stages Ubisoft are
clearly casting a very wide net and it's
good it's ambitious the question is will
they be able to execute on it it does
seem as if we're going to be getting a
lot more concrete information come si
which is only like two months away so
stay tuned until then enjoy the new
season and just be psyched about Siege
again the game continues
in the best state it's ever been and the
hope is that soon enough that will also
be true of the Esports scene
see you next time
dude if you have not if you don't know
blast production value they are just
like
describe it I I don't know like they're
putting on the next major in Paris uh
for a reason it's gonna be a blast
that's literally what I think the like
what weigh you the Esports director of
Siege said like when they did the sign
off on the video he's like have a blast
with the new season and then they did
the like the yeah yeah it was so funny